hey let's talk about Joe Biden we got
this story from the New York Post Biden
jokes he's really not Irish because he's
sober doesn't have relatives in jail I
I'm sorry guys I gotta say it based like
this was a funny racist joke made by Joe
Biden you know what I mean like I
remember asking Sheamus if it was racist
to make jokes about Irish people and he
said yes what was that Sheamus you you
actually you don't like the jokes you
think it's derogatory on St Patrick's
Day on St Patrick's Day of all what
well come on that's a little harsh isn't
it yeah anyway we were what we were
saying I'm Irish so I'm allowed to make
these jokes is anybody else Irish in
here yeah yeah I am failure no I am not
no Jenny you're not I'm Jewish Jewish oh
man so there's three three people who
are part Irish so we're all automated if
you guys make any jokes then we'll kick
you out because I honestly think it's a
hilarious joke that Joe Biden made it's
fine I know it's funny like he's wow
that's that's that's shockingly
ethnically offensive it sounds like a
trump line I know right
like if you replaced Irish with black
and he was a like Barack Obama made a
joke about it being black he's like
because I don't eat this and have like
it would be the most defense I mean even
for a black dude to say it would be so
danger Will racist no but you're right
like saying saying a certain ethnicity
is you know only real if they're drunk
and in jail
stereotype I know it's funny but is he
is he he's Irish so he's allowed to say
it right yes
I mean I'm how you guys doing I'm
chilling I'm not used to being the butt
of jokes like racially so I don't know
how sensitive what you should do about
racially insensitive jokes I've never
really been that bothered by them you
should probably just not make them it's
a safe bet and just let other people
make them don't be like hey well I mean
look I mean anytime you're I personally
I'm not gonna police someone else like
I'm not gonna be like man you shouldn't
say this or you shouldn't say that like
if someone says something offensive I'm
gonna be like
you know look and you know do that the
the whole Homer Simpson
fading back into the uh the Hedge behind
him you know Dave Chappelle did a bit on
one of his comedy specials where he
squinted his eyes and his mouth and then
made like offensive Asian stereotypes
and I laughed my ass off at it yeah and
then I guess what happens is if the woke
people are like that was offensive and I
say something like you're correct
they'll go well because you're Asian you
understand but if I say actually my
family's party Asian we found it
hilarious I'll say well you've
internalized your white supremacy or
something you you're white inside that's
exactly how I feel because he makes
jokes against Jews and then the Jewish
Community like freaks out and you're
like no calm down like then every time
it's like boy who cried wolf it's like
every time you like freak out it's
something small and then when something
really big happens it's gonna be like oh
whatever well trumped Arrangement
syndrome's real yeah like Sam Harris
that that guy's brain is just gone
you know he was like he did that podcast
with Lex Friedman and he's like it's
it's you who have Trump derangement
syndrome if you support Trump and it's
like I saw um who was it uh Joe Walsh I
think it was yeah he's a clown he said
something like why don't you want to be
woke and then I'm just like dude you I
was like bro cause you're in a cult
these people are like if you disagree
with me you love Trump and I'm like it
was really funny when Dave Smith who
hopefully announces he's running for the
for the for president uh for the
presidency as a Libertarian he was on
this show and they were like use Trump
supporters and he's like I'm a
Libertarian he's like I hate Trump I
don't like the guy like why are you
assuming because they're an occult they
their their brains are an occult they
they live in a world where there's only
Trump or no Trump and if you disagree
with them because Biden's bad then you
must love Trump even if you're actively
smack talking Trump they just it's a
cult man I wonder what cult I'm in I
feel like everybody's gonna call
graphene the graphene call yeah you
won't let it go man so Mars some kind of
Earth worship or something like that the
Gaia probably something Cult of the
eminent Gaia yeah something something
thing something earthy crunchy I do
believe that like Consciousness is is a
spirit is like a magnetic field yeah
other people start to believe you know
when I was started making YouTube videos
it was a long time ago
you do no oh okay good uh I it got very
culty like like internet video produces
Cults of Personality where you become
obsessed or in love with the person you
watch and you subscribe to them and you
pay them and like you become you support
them and you follow them and it's like
it can if you bear your soul to that it
can become very like culty like weirdly
culty the nice thing what you do is it's
a business for you you keep it very
business oriented it's very professional
I mean that's true for any famous person
you know yes like yeah you've got all
these celebrities who are doing only
fans they're not doing porn though
they're just posting bikini photos or
whatever and they're making millions in
like days when you get emotional and
then they start to get attached to that
you'll notice they scream your name and
they don't care what you're talking
about that's when it's like this is
called I don't like it can I just can I
pretend I'm offended at Joe Biden's
Irish comments and like impeach him for
it or something
oh geez that was that's like he said the
n-word for Irish people violence you
know yeah it was violent he attacked me
I think I'm gonna need uh I'm gonna need
him to be impeached Jim Jordan or Matt
Gates if uh you could just maybe come in
this weekend and file those impeachment
papers this is like getting dealt a
trump card an Ace of Spades when you're
playing Spades and you're like holy I
get to hold this in my hand now and this
is gonna guarantee I don't lose every
hand no they don't care because he's
indicating that it's okay to make Racist
Jokes which it is we it's not it's free
speech you're allowed to do that so now
you need a video of a little kid who's
like watching and going haha Irish
people are dumb and saying stuff like
that look what Joe Biden has done to
these children that's the downside of
racist jokes but yeah that's life you
know you need strong parents to tell
kids like you're gonna hear and see this
stuff
I guess yeah if you're white passing it
you can be racist yeah if you're Irish
but you pass for white then you're okay
because no one will know that you're
drunk or in jail Irish people are not
white they I guess I mean Luke's Luke's
got blonde hair and blue eyes and they
don't yeah he's a slob he's not well
you know a man I I mean it does it
shouldn't surprise anyone that Joe Biden
said something like that it's it's not
offensive to
I mean anyone really I mean for the most
part most people just are going to be
like whatever I don't I don't imagine
there's going to be a significant uh
constituency of of Irish people that are
going to actually be up in arms about it
I mean I I just I just don't don't
imagine that they're gonna have anything
to say about it so it's it's going to go
away and whatever but and you should
expect something brainless to come out
of Joe Biden's mouth because you know by
noon time he's out of it Joe Biden could
actually make disparaging comments about
like black people and they wouldn't care
they would they would immediately
respond with well Donald Trump called
Mexicans rapists or whatever so you have
nowhere you have no room to talk or
whatever and you're going to be like he
never said that dude but they don't care
it is it is it is a situation you know
the the hierarchy of of acceptable
people and unacceptable people so there
is that but again it's just a matter of
Joe Biden is like they're they're just
gonna ignore whatever he says for two
reasons one he's the the
he's the president and he's on the left
ostensibly and two because they make
excuses for him because he's got tapioca
for brains
right I mean yeah like if they really
were to respond to this they'd say oh
well Old Joe's got brain issues so we
forgive him and it's like oh now he's
got brain issues and and it's fine I
mean obviously that you know it was vote
for Joe Biden everyone knew he was a a
mess two years ago and Sheamus and I are
uh starting a non-profit to advocate for
the rights of Irish people
it's uh it's called people organizing
together against true oppression
yeah I'm gonna wait for people in the
audience to put that one together yeah
write that down it'll make more sense
there's actually a a bit we wrote for
Cass Castle
because I was watching Leprechaun one
day this is a True Story and there's a
scene in Leprechaun where the leprechaun
bites a guy and then he starts turning
Irish I'm not even kidding he literally
starts turning to an Irish guy and he's
like he goes to he's like a normal guy
and he gets bitten and then he I love
those movies he goes to a restaurant and
he's like I'll have the mashed potatoes
the french fries the waffle fries sweet
potato fries the tater tots and then
he's just got nothing but potato and
he's like eating it and then this is a
true story Sheamus walks in the living
room and he's like what's up buddy what
are you watching and then he turns and
looks at the TV and he goes what the he
was like yo this is the most racist
thing I've ever seen and I was like yes
leprechaun and he was like is he just
stuffing potatoes and I'm like yeah he's
eating potatoes and he was like oh my
God so then we wrote a bit about people
organizing together against true
oppression potato in case you haven't
figured that is it in in regards to the
way that critical theorists view Society
is it only racist if you make fun of a
marginalized Community or is it is it
still race if you make fun of a
non-marginalized community but it's okay
that it's racist it's not so according
to the left it's not racist if you're
punching up yeah racism is Prejudice
plus power it can only be applied to
those who are weaker than you so if a
white homeless guy is laying on the
ground with no teeth and he's and he's
shivering in the cold and then you know
a marginalized person walks by him and
stumbles on him and the white homeless
guy says hey don't you stumble on me
they're gonna be like whoa that was
racist like how dare you like because
he's white then that was the matter that
he's dying it would make people try to
become victims and marginalized so that
they can protect themselves from the
racist jokes that's that's the standard
Behavior now people do it all the time
they constantly are using a victimhood
or whatever to as insulation where's the
Irish reparations you know we're talking
about San Francisco and and they're
saying if you identify as black you
qualify if you live there and you
identify as black what what about you
know Irish need not apply it's the it's
the McDonald's large foreign
against Irish people I I think Irish
people should get reparations you know
the government should give me your money
the Irish died and droves trying to do
the uh Erie Canal you know they that was
slave labor uh that's right so that's
that's exactly right is it because the
bridge people have suffered and have
been oppressed historically and you know
like I should get money from the
government for free by the way
propaganda British propaganda because
they hated the Irish because they were
like island island barbarians that
wouldn't capitulate to the Empire well
the Irish and the British have always
had uh issues with each other uh there
there's a lot of protestant and Catholic
animosity involved in that I don't know
the details I'm not interested in the
politics on the uh those little uh let's
I don't think they're actually
barbarians they come from Barbarian
tribes or whatever you want to call them
the tribes back in the day thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time